Oh
this episode is brought to you back
bevel the first and only shaving system
designed specifically for curly and
sensitive skin
check out get bevel dot-com slash
Hannibal today we buy the bevel trimmer
get the first month of the savings
system free as get beveled DICOM slash
animal
there are a lot of things that could
stress you out or get you down have you
thought about going to therapy but found
it too inconvenient to experience or
just too embarrassing to make it into an
office they give talk space a trial
talk space is the online therapy company
they make it easy to connect with a
licensed therapist handpicked just for
you for as little as thirty two dollars
a week using talk space you can text
audio and video message your therapist
as much as you want your talk space
therapist can listen to you vit about
work of family explore your
relationships with the people around you
and if you put you on the path to a half
of your life to sign up or learn more go
to talk space.com and as a special offer
for our listeners you can use coupon
code Hannibal to get $30 off your first
month and show your support for this
podcast that's cold Hannibal I visited
talk space.com slash Hannibal talk space
therapy for how we live today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up you up yeah how's it going
welcome so uh
Ezra Mopar guys live here Atlanta
Hannibal Burres Tony [ __ ] yes al
Jackson Jackson thank you all for for
coming
it's 2:30 on 4/20 that was a choice I
wanted you to know that that was a
choice I wanted to do an event on 4/20
but I didn't want it to be at 4:20 so I
was I want to do this at 2:30 yeah
you're undercut Benson my [ __ ] is
earlier and I don't want it to be right
at 4:20 that's how deep in my head I am
I didn't want it to be right at that
time but I appreciate you all coming
it's fun to do stuff at the daytime and
get [ __ ] up cuz I think if you get a
little [ __ ] up during the day you have
interesting evening or no evening it's
one of those you could end up going to
sleep fully clothed 7:00 or maybe you
have your nighttime in afternoon your
nighttime you can still meet somebody in
find love early so you saying you could
have like 10:30 p.m. energy at 5 p.m.
yeah I appreciate you all coming out and
then I felt bad for charge of $20 so I
picked up the drinks
[Laughter]
give it up yeah drinks on the house
don't be a weirdo about it though ha I
am generous was still reasonable don't
don't [ __ ] face at the bar you know who
you are
drink I want to see like a bottle of
sparkling champagne come out as soon as
you say that get it going cuz I've been
I've been doing this morning I've been
doing stand-up lately yeah yeah cuz you
could do this because we do it live
occasionally but we do it more it's
nicer to just tell jokes without having
to stare at strangers like I paid $40
for this what does a stand-up show like
I got a babysitter definitely less
pressure it'd be weird people that's the
thing when you do a show you think okay
I booked that we did a show last night
in Atlanta you think I'm coming from
Columbus Georgia nothing ever happens
here I got the pressure of Columbus I
know I have the pressure of your town
being garbage that's real so that's why
I like doing a podcast better cuz I
don't have to look at somebody that
drove three hours yeah and took a day
off and then one day like oh no he just
talks about having money now it's way
different than animal furnace I don't
know if you randomly brought up Columbus
Georgia but I did a gig there once yeah
and I had the a I did a golf like a golf
club and whatever you call it coughing
community what is a golf club Country
Club whatever the foot clearly I don't I
wasn't no I was yeah no I don't need I
couldn't even think of the word Oh
and I was leaving leaving a gig wait and
first I wanna before you get into the
gig I want to just know how it came
about I gotta I gotta booked like you
like sometimes people see you in they're
like yo do you do private events here
like if you have money I'll do anything
no I don't care and then so he was like
yo meme up in this so like it was at a
private golf Country Club and you could
tell like I was doing it was like just
for like 20 rich white dudes was like
that's that Country Club it was some
weird [ __ ] word like they clearly didn't
give a [ __ ] about what they were paying
me like they paid yeah and so I had to
leave and I stopped at got gas and I
went inside and I don't like the clerk
Mike goes eh India do and I was just
saying homey moved to the left a little
bit there's some weird over shoulder and
I looked and they were like they were
selling these little glass vials with
tiny plastic red roses in it and I was
like what is that and he goes you give
these to your girlfriend and I was like
you could also probably smoked crystal
meth out of that and he was like look
bro I just sell it and I was just like
this dude was selling meth pipes but
they have like a little plastic rose in
it so like oh so like well branded meth
it was just like that's how many people
did meth in that town is that they sewed
it at the gas station but the way to day
pass it all said he not just selling
glass pipes they put this little 1 cent
rose in it so they're like oh is your
romantic it's like yeah you can also
smoke crack out of this that's one it
was amazing right Apple ism I feel like
meth as a drug is a bit too demonized
and there's you you only hear about the
worst cases of meth you see the
before-and-after pic yeah yeah but you
don't really hear about the casual meth
user which really exists as somebody
that it's just somebody again I do met
and also I'm a lawyer it's I mean it's
adderall but adderall is basically meth
is just like a low-key man yeah it's
clean meth some were saying is do meth
but you're doing adderall you're already
on meth have just a little bit don't get
too into it and also I just feel like
wait Hannah will tell me why wait you
think black people don't do meth that's
what I was about to get into because we
just scared of here's my well you I've
heard about you I've heard about white
people doing crack casually I don't know
I don't white friends that are done
crash the crack and then I went back to
being regular oh I do crack and I'm
still regular and then but black people
don't dabble in crack you just hear
about horrible black crack stories with
I have family members that have done
cracking in the yeah he's on crack
heeding that part of the family until
you get his [ __ ] together but then yeah
so cuz we scared it crack but then I
wonder if black people don't handle
crack as well but maybe we can handle
math better because it seemed like why
people struggle with meth
like why people struggle with math
differently like an enzyme or something
and so maybe black people maybe we can
handle math really chill but we so
scared of it yeah 43 that's a great
theory a little bit a smidgen a dab a
little bit wait how do you even do math
I feel like this is more of a Q&A at
this point but you guys iconic is the
vapor vapor oh I think you cook it on
the foil and then it makes a vapor is
that what you think Tony they're really
nailing it right no I see you got a
straw and you you cook the underneath
the foil and then you inhale with the
straw I mean it looks like what a
crackhead does I mean it's a crackhead
ish thing to do is it only one way of
doing it or can you you could snort it
to you snort it yeah can you spread it
on your gums I don't know how far that
goes I think you could stick it up your
ass like most of you can stick up your
ass when you do a rectally that's rock
bottom
yeah it also realize it or not you see
some people I think but chugging vodka
yeah is a shotgun liqueur into their ass
looks like a college thing can you go
right into partying after that oh do you
I think you keep just pull up your pants
like okay what's the next song yeah wait
yeah is that the beginning of the night
like is that your pregame or is that
your put like I think this is more like
tonight ends right I'm [ __ ] yes my
friend initiation [ __ ] like you gonna
take this bin yes like I think that's
what's probably more for or are they
more efficient way like my mouth is pure
vessel liquor only goes in my [ __ ]
where [ __ ] goes yep what mouth is for
just dreams to spout out in motivation I
feel like where we are right now if
somebody if you give us a good
scientific reason we could be talked
into it yeah you know I'm saying cuz
like what if it's just more efficient to
put it because you think about your
mouth that's gonna take away some of the
whatever the drug then it's got a pass
to your digestive system that's gonna
cut it in half so by the time it goes to
all the food is in your stomach already
by the time it gets into your
bloodstream it's not what you took but
if it goes straight to the ass that way
that's what I heard like when you like
my set is true
less people stick Molly up their ass
because they say it hits you faster and
it's stronger cuz all all the vessels
but how do you stick it up do you leave
it like a suppository I don't know how
it's done but you just you it goes in
your ass
well I think here's my counterpoint
against it cuz I can argue for it and
against it you can't really one thing
about having a drink is that you can
Cheers
you can't go but the box with somebody
yeah I mean you can but it's just not
good you can ask for assistance yeah we
had a guest that's how that's the smooth
segue I think he wanted a Eric Andre
show The Wanted a few two time guests
because a lot of people do that [ __ ] I
don't want to be a part of that name
y'all muhfuckas appraised I don't want
to done no no no what who's this naw
he's been on season 1 and season 3 from
Atlanta it's his birthday today
outstanding artist and hilarious do
please welcome
kill the mic everybody kilobyte kill the
mic in the house what show your respect
Atlanta kill the mic what's that it man
we was how you talk about some [ __ ]
I don't actually bronze to come out and
run on a treadmill you I think you might
be the only two times twice outside of
you know fake Russell Brand and those
types you're the only you being this
done it twice how y'all doing happy
birthday yeah thank you how do you man
man I'm 42 years old today 42 42 years
young I grew up in the crack era so most
of my friends died at 17 and [ __ ] so I'm
happy to make it you drive-by places
Atlantic like yeah whoo died there and
now it's a condominium with the hipsters
yeah strange and exciting place on the
west side these days I was literally
going through out one of the roughest
most [ __ ] up streets in the 90s and I
saw like a white lady riding her bike
and I knew like I was like the world is
gonna be okay I was like I was like
officially Atlanta's turned the corner
welcome back white people I don't know
if any of you guys remember like there
used to be an older bateria neil bortz
who i'm a fan of his crazy ass he his
job for 20
years was to scare white people from
coming in the city what I secretly think
he had like a deal with black leaders in
Atlanta to keep white people in the
suburbs now that he's gone and the
children and grandchildren of those
white people have moved into the city
it's become like like Mecca and he's
just left for Florida like [ __ ] that
dude neil bortz he's a cool old guy but
he's crazy as [ __ ] she knows he's have a
radio show yeah you have a show this is
the show
don't go to Atlanta you will die if you
go to a Braves game someone was murdered
watching Dominique slam-dunking like
people who live people who live ten
miles above it man in Cobb County we're
too afraid the [ __ ] is wrong with you
it's Atlanta like it's cool black people
it's not like Detroit like you in
Baltimore black people got jobs I don't
want to kill nobody
they might want to [ __ ] your daughters
but they don't want to my I was running
for mayor next go-around yeah I don't
want to [ __ ] anyone's daughter have a
mic from there that'd be a that'd be a
disaster my show you [ __ ] want
to rebuild 85 so what do we get out of
this so I talked about his theory on the
bridge what those those crack stem
charges talk about you about it roses in
we're supposed to believe a [ __ ]
mentally disabled man burnt down a
highway with one of those a bit lighter
and a brillo yeah for those you gotta
know what you do is you buy those little
rolls and some of you people know why
people have actually done a little crack
so look you're bad one of those roses
you take the rolls out you take brillo
your stuff brillo to the look he knows
your stuff RIT on the other side put
your crack in it
smoke your crack through your billow
then they got what they call pushing the
shooter where all the residue is caught
then they push the riddle to the other
side he's really remembering now
[ __ ] again you're like boom now
white people can end that about Sunday
morning 4:50 and go back to work black
people do that [ __ ] in 20 years later
they come out the other side like I
missed the 90s so we're supposed to
believe a guy burnt down expressway with
one of those that definitely is a
conspiracy theory I could ride with
that's I don't believe it oh [ __ ] I mean
you see how I failed clean like it felt
like just this section needs to fall
because [ __ ] Linux yeah okay so what
what's the motivation what's the
motivation of sixty million dollars came
the next day that brought some jobs
whatever keeps people in helmets invest
director traffic in Atlanta is a good
thing yeah you know and I'm gonna tell
you what it did all those people that
were really afraid to come to Atlanta
yeah I'm finally have to ride the
[ __ ] bus now so we're good well will
within out lifetime we'll see a train
that makes it to Acworth you know what I
mean
oh man catching the train to Dacula you
know finally we don't have to Rev our
[ __ ] Honda three hours ahead of work
to get there it was a conspiracy to make
it work 20% up I saw more white folks on
martyr than Braves opening day that [ __ ]
was amazing yeah I was like Dale Murphy
unlike most guys I'm actually from here
just kind of moved here to figured it
out but I'm from right there that way
that's cool oh I'll never take the bus
no matter how much it make is more
convenient it was a black man of means I
don't take buses anymore either I Drive
to the games
I don't even over file the days I was
pouring a child and I'll martyr [ __ ]
martyr I have a muscle car now I
remember riding Martin man when you
couldn't even wear Jordans on Mario's
like me I feel like an robbed today just
you just are where your [ __ ]
flip-flops of socks robbing somebody of
their shoes feels like even if give me
those first X massage you wear
that's what sighs you know what sighs
arose and you were naive you're a knife
great with size you wear yeah Robert
yeah Ronald and next thing you know you
got to make a decision yeah am I gonna
fight 14 guys from [ __ ] alternative
school or walk home and my [ __ ] socks
all right
so after we robbed the kid be okay I
gave them the socks back from that way
do you put the shoes on out the you
robbed now you spray them first always a
little [ __ ] feet bin you go get your
Grandpa's to enact in his frame how does
it feel to be one of the top workout
music creators dad when I go workout I
want that [ __ ] treadmill doing about
a four like man how about working and
the [ __ ] 125 pound of list 225
white woman next to me listen to our
yeah yeah yeah yeah King of [ __ ]
CrossFit for life of my [ __ ] you [ __ ]
your life you know me but I've lost 15
pounds yeah maintaining great focus
during his interview y'all
you all can't see but yes 17 Miss Carr a
lot of Atlanta strippers are calling me
and my wife right now
like y'all gonna be that we saw about we
bright
so be cheese I'm like okay yes there you
go can either I just met last night yeah
man right cool cool you having a party
having a party we're gonna have a party
and pull up you pull up your old school
or your car yeah you come you smoke I've
got like a half a pound or so you smoke
is that a club club yeah it's right next
my first barber shop yeah we have two
that are functioning now and one that's
gonna open in a few months over in the
West End
yeah I'm bad at clubs no it's not like
one else clubs no no it's a lounge but
the lounges of we're 40 year old black
people go to avoid their children you
know their their beds there there's like
I'll pull your pants up ruling [ __ ] no
white t-shirts allowed you know like you
know my kids could come which makes me
more comfortable
what is your weird as talking about our
game we got some weird girls coming to
we got out we got an eclectic mix we got
there from strippers and socialite you
know people were we had to show last
night at masquerade people will fight
ever rapidly except me
it's funny like you talk to your home
your associate or you like yeah coming
out to see you so he's like oh man TI
songs break it down yo let's break it
down I was like goddamn overcoming it
we'll have a joke for you soon I'll just
talk tell them you had a funny ass bit
about him though yeah yeah I hope he
comes out checks it out you guys do you
try to put like I was like when I saw
that movie I just like oh Eric's gonna
get shot today
there was a thing sometimes on the show
Jimmy flavor yeah where it's certain
people we have the bid set up but I sum
up some people I'm I don't know already
so I'm able to disconnect a little bit
yeah but when it's some people that I'm
a fan of we were we would had the bit
when we were upset in Ti
oh yeah and so I was hard for me to get
into it because I'm I'm [ __ ] with him
I he may what you know I remember
exactly where I was the first time I
know I don't want to play a practical
joke on one of your heroes complain
about the show be a standing room mostly
show with standing the horror of this
show this comedy show being standing as
a your city's infrastructure is
crumbling you can handle this I mean I
the same type of [ __ ] that go
to Coachella and stand around for 12
hours for music I mean is now I don't
have a band you can't exact up here's
the thing also the buildings where is
all seated they cost more money to rip
[Laughter]
unions and [ __ ] is different parts of
this you have to be efficient hey Mike
can we get into some run the jewels out
by forth together cuz he did my solo
record
rap music he has the third run the
jewels yes uh yeah you can clap for that
us don't belong yeah yeah well how did
you got wait I'm sure you I'm sure you
probably answer this a million times
before but
how did you guys how did you guys link
up in the first yes there's a there's a
brilliant executive heck over at Cartoon
Network named Jason DeMarco who happens
to be a friend of both of ours yeah he's
a very cool guy drives muscle cars yeah
dog he just we when he won't ask me to
do rap music he was like yo essentially
I want you to just be free to make your
America's Most Wanted and say anything
you want to say yeah we put LP and I'm
just do do together and they just
blossomed from there you know because I
was a fan of yours
even before the jewels and hearing you
on LPS Beach is perfect it made me so
happy I knew the first day the first day
we won the studio when a patchwork I'm
not far from here the first time we
played a beat I was like this one
suppose we make immediately it was like
a scene from Titanic I feel like I feel
like anybody on on lp's beats enhances
him someone like the cannibal ox guys
like you know after like these other
people I however feel I was born to rap
on his beat yeah you guys that's no dis
anyone else but I literally feel like
two pieces of a puzzle [ __ ] yeah it
worked so well and I like that he just
felt zero didn't he stop doing solos
[ __ ] and just went all the way with run
the jewels yeah you do what works man
what keeps you working 150 200 days a
year
yeah it's amazing it's been a blessing
just to connect with the audience yeah I
had to kill my audience of course he had
a company flowing audience in those two
audiences we thought would merge and
converge but with that this whole like
your own niche mic your fans are so like
I wouldn't say cult but I'd say like
your your fans are just like we get up
there there's a real energy exchange and
I'm happy to be a part of community like
you know run the jewels
started as some [ __ ] they used to say in
80s like run your sneakers run your
jewels and you know those cheesy rap
losers or LL Cool J song you know preach
hands in the air I leave them there run
the jewels you know just a badass [ __ ]
to say from the 80s because you know
we're old rapid men now you know yeah
and when we start seeing kids like I
have a
a chain that's the winged victory of the
motorist in the Louvre museum in Paris
when kids start going to the Louvre
throwing a runner Jules kids start
throwing it up at their weddings when
they [ __ ] climb mountains and Trek
[ __ ] marathons and [ __ ] I was like oh
[ __ ]
this is a little bigger than I'm robbing
you for your sneakers on the train they
have since giving it a new meaning of
just take your life in your own hands
and do the most with it and I'm proud to
be a part of it you know yes great
energy it out when y'all are rappin to
just sound like you punching [ __ ] energy
to it we used to get hype tonight [ __ ]
before the show guy was talking but
always I was just there he's leaving or
either/or but we gotta we got to make
sure we converged or a big festival with
something together yeah Jules why you
having sex yeah yeah my wife puts it all
to say it go hard Big Daddy
I come here my wrassling mass going out
the top rope see like what a girl says
that to me like my dick would crumble
under that pressure
what's your face is for a boy try your
best women respect a man that works hard
try me I feel the pressure if I don't do
well now broad city is losing a fan
[Laughter]
how many people are high as [ __ ] right
now yeah something was a good amount of
people as [ __ ] that is a big reason I'm
voting for [ __ ] you know I get
inspired when I do this I'm in run the
jewels what I mean just never loses
never Cinelli and while we [ __ ]
auto-tune this out just I'm like I like
it on other people I just think on me I
shouldn't wear tight jeans and
sweatshirts have you guys seen the new
era of fat kids god bless your little
fat souls they think huh they've took in
this equality [ __ ] too much like I'm
equal to all my friends no [ __ ]
you a three extra little one xswim
[ __ ] got the bottom of his belly out
of [ __ ] like the [ __ ] are you doing man
like you're still fat broke not me
[ __ ] wildly across the goddamn
Street hogs wait like no I was a little
chubby kid but my mom bought me the
husky jeans give you a little gift so
you can still play 34 husky from Sears &
Roebuck have yeah that was Anna Sultan
never talked to me like that again
endorsement pitch what somebody said hey
you should do this does anybody watch
animals tour at last four years of my
life so I get a call from Big Boi he's
like your kid I was like what's up he's
like man they want us to do this show
called animals I was like worried so
yeah they wants to write a rap like
we're these two animals and we live in
New York City you I was like word let's
get it he was like yeah they wants to be
raccoons I was like whole
I was like I'm sure that these are young
white progressive riders I'm sure that
they're down for the calls they
supported Bernie and outcasts fans but
they don't really get the correlation of
the word raccoon and black person that
it just doesn't quite go right where
we're from you can't as a black man
become a [ __ ] you can't play for the
raccoons
you can't like raccoon can't wear
raccoon hat post Fat Boys era like the
[ __ ] won't work so we ended up being
foxes because I hit the note back to
just as a dear white friends of mine
never acts your [ __ ] black friends to
play a raccoon in any form grey play or
television production wait so what
season was this that was like a few
weeks ago
Oh besides it come on we live on the
road we don't see the [ __ ] you know
afterwards I can't wait to see it was
pretty good but maybe they wanted to
make it rap codes that sounds like
something that like Minister Farrakhan
calls us what do you think you're out
here you
[Music]
the only saber system designed
specifically for coarse curly and
sensitive skin and if you've been
patiently waiting for the bevel trimmer
the wait is over all orders shipping now
check out get beveled comm slash
Hannibal today when you get when you buy
the beveled trimmer you get the first
month for the shaving system free that's
get bevel calm slash Hannibal hey are
you upset you got some weird stuff
happening you don't know who to turn to
you don't have a car or like leaving
places well use talk space is text-based
therapy talk space matches you with a
therapist and you can just get therapy
on your phone or tablet or computer or
you can send them video messages it's
great man check it out at talk space.com
slash hannibal google talk space and
look up all the great reviews from
people that's used it
these people were messes before they
started using talk space now everything
is chill as a special offer you use
promo code Hannibal get $30 off of your
first month $30 that's a cost of a
margarita in Manhattan and we giving you
that off go to talk space.com slash
Hannibal use the promo code show support
for the podcast and also support for
your own mental health talk space
[Music]
[Music]
just a great fried chicken spot yeah
unless they're from Nashville I'm gonna
tell you that though I will say why
people of Nashville know they're
comfortable in my heart but I I take the
suggestion right it's kind of south bar
to his capital of Mississippi yeah I
trust whites other people like no other
people on earth let me tell you
something look if you get the right
white southerner they still cook with
lard those [ __ ] yeah like once
you start going down Alabama you tell my
good eatin now I don't trust white
southern city folks oh I'm scared all
these [ __ ] moving to Atlanta
but if you're from making out your mom's
food yeah when you cook with lard man
there's a whole nother thing even just
cooking fries as I work out and cursor
out on a tray you're quite the foodie
aren't you and I'm not saying this ain't
McDonald's hot tea yeah so when you go
out when you go out on the road and
you're you traveling you're doing shows
do you do you go to the baller spots the
Michelin star restaurants no no you
don't you don't do that I will like a
good steak house I'll go to but like we
were in Paris two weeks ago and we found
a 24-hour Caribbean spot in the middle
of Paris it was it was literally the
door look like hostel and the guy drove
us up and he's just like that's there's
no one here you know really like [ __ ]
that get out of car knock on that door
white man oh my god or a night alley I
saw hostel he knocks and get a reply
boop we're out the car we're in there it
is zebra stripes red lamps pictures of
Little John 50-cent I'm like all me my
auntie's basement that's great food in
the middle
tonight I hired we hired for our
security and as a trainer if you follow
me on instagram josh spice the [ __ ]
child making evil ass [ __ ] workout
master he finds Jamaican food we could
be in Antarctica he'd find Jamaican
restaurant so I eat a lot of eat a lot
of peas and rice and [ __ ] Yard Man food
as he calls it yeah yeah such a
beautiful thing dude I feel like on the
road that's the one thing I miss the
most is just like you talking about that
auntie cooking yeah Valerie you know I
just I just pulled her so I was like
what is your fried chicken tastes like
this why and she was like cuz I take
each piece and I seasoned it by hand
Chimere like she never got married and
she's fine were like you have that on
and you you be looking at a booty and
you're like I shouldn't be doing it yeah
but it's amazing exact an amazing is
unreal it's like it makes you
uncomfortable Valerie's not married no
never got married I mean she could like
she's not from Cleveland I like y'all
have no off like a guy who a really
awful but he'd be around at all advanced
yeah she went on my own that's what a
writer she is she'd been with uh with my
uncle has been locked up for he got 15
years and he probably bent antenna she's
just wait she's [ __ ] somebody oh [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of like off event y'all
know you been to jail but hey yo ladies
probably [ __ ] a comedian or rapper
but don't worry we ain't coming back out
you get what needed to be said that's
the truth we are not coming back not
coming back at the old man get out we're
not [ __ ] noble boys man I'm gonna
[ __ ] this [ __ ] out you these two girls
that he's in I will be your friend we
might take one trip that you'll remember
forever
that [ __ ] get out of jail - that [ __ ]
won't not Mac I think honestly that's
why that's why [ __ ] try to ten years
kill a [ __ ] bout that
okay cook out a big-ass heberto
[ __ ] hallory yeah she's a real
deal man she fun as [ __ ] to drinks but I
always said there's a theory I have
where I feel like girls have sex with
traveling entertainers not because we're
particularly good-looking or whatever
it's just that we're leaving it's an
invasion we're leaving and if you live
in a city like Atlanta is a big-ass city
so you have to work but if you deliver
even like a kind of mid major city like
Louisville if you go there but ten bars
there 20 bars yeah if you a girl if you
[ __ ] dude if you [ __ ] five guys that
year you gonna get a rep you gonna see
him out in other places but if you
[ __ ] do it is leaving that's why
flight attendants get ass cuz they leave
it yeah as long as you promise you
leaving mm-hmm no [ __ ] you
I like flight attendants they are an
adventurous Bunch yeah like just in
terms of not even just on some sex and
while [ __ ] this is like you know Tanisha
grew up in the housing projects of
Atlanta and Tanisha isn't [ __ ] Cozumel
right now doing cocaine and sipping
margaritas with white men she doesn't
even know like she never dreamed of this
life when she was at Frederick Douglass
High School and all of a sudden its
she's like there's planes that go other
places higher bucket chanita takes the
world have y'all done any corporate
events Oh vitamin water what happens
when you mix Jeremiah R&B superstar with
run the jewels in vitamin water what
happens is you get a call at [ __ ] an
odd hour of the night hey how would you
guys like to make $60,000 in the more
light [ __ ] it yeah what not you're still
in a stupor and high and drunk hey you
guys are gonna be performing for vital
water [ __ ] it up down with 50 cent let's
get it my citizen New York New York is
that you already in New York as a last
minute day why exactly we show up places
filled with call center s tight black
women that is such a specific genre yeah
oh my god oh she misses supplies a seat
you know know who though she's on the
phone I'm trying to remain professional
with you sir exactly hurt her sometimes
boyfriend is with her who actually knows
run the jewels right cuz he's not the
guy with the money he's the guy she just
likes for cultural [ __ ] Museum guy
[ __ ] once a month you honor me I show
up on the stage FDJ if he looks at us
like look look [ __ ] and L ain't even
black I'm just all this [ __ ] is going
down we step out there all the duels all
in sunlight oh there's I promise you
seven white kids in a room of black
Barbie Barbie ISM that are going run the
jewels yeah all the black girls look
over like well let's see what they got
we can't all right before we go stage is
the vitamin water if it
there'll be no profanity sell the [ __ ]
we got on stage and we cursed our
[ __ ] asses off we shocked and
horrified every [ __ ] in the room
those seven white kids went insane like
Joan of Arc was taking [ __ ] friends
the guys in the role were like finally
some [ __ ] real rap music and the
black women were like hi where's
Jeremiah that was when we officially
stopped doing corporate events
you know I saw I saw a couple of times I
don't know I don't know if I'm tripping
but was it once or twice which somebody
rushed the stage and tried to attack I
don't like you and another time a guy
jumped on stage and tried to snatch the
mr. kilims else things off we just beat
the [ __ ] out of him no that's per rap
you know
do you see [ __ ] out of the people who
love you so much they want to steal [ __ ]
like fit this girl shakes your hand
pulls y'all stay Tomahawk Chop babysit
that chick yeah yeah those are the only
times otherwise she's pretty cool man I
wish like the audience we have is pretty
cool art is it's not like the crock era
where you could go see Little John and
died the same night yeah yeah you guys
ever like it seems like you guys have a
pretty smart fanbase we do down into the
crowded mosh about with them I don't
shop into anything but a pool thanks for
doing this on your birthday many love
this guy man like like he this guy's
just he's a great comedian human being
now no God no all yeah well I saw your
parents I just felt like I knew you but
you look like your mom it was mom and
dad yeah you and I was like maybe from a
decent background I tell people all the
time I call myself a middle-class rap
dad you are middle-class like the [ __ ] I
know my key is making it a night like if
you're rich you kinda have prepared your
kids to make it right you know on
boarding school I've invested um if
you're really destitute and poor you've
done [ __ ] like fish hunt but in the
middle it's all great you know I mean
like people are man I'm voting for this
person for a better school district did
your child scholarship in the college up
your investment fail then like just be
honest about so our middle class is
[ __ ] til my children can prove
otherwise
yeah little [ __ ] I still don't
know exactly what my dad did for ephedra
yeah I know way he worked he made away
he works for Union Pacific Railroad
a lot of money a lot of money
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
no this is weirdest [ __ ] I never told
you HB Ida ex-girlfriend she's a doctor
now you [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up she's fine
too I was you know like when you young
you just don't realize she has a brother
named Marcus and she found out like way
she's like 20 that her dad who was a
weird do had like nine other sons all
across the country named Marcus but but
they all spelled it different least like
somewhere ma RQ somewhere ma RCU but
they were all some versions of marks or
so for bits it's wrong yeah yeah but
just differentiate it like with
different moms there's just different
sons all named Marcus weird and that's
that helps me because whenever I think
I'm really weird and extreme I hear
stories like that and say I'm alright
[Laughter]
would never do that
Annabelle I BL never do that I'm decent
yeah I was in the Louvre Museum with my
wife yeah no I'm not we paid someone to
take us and drive us around and give us
art lessons [ __ ] that I really didn't
need cuz I was an art nerd ASCII in any
way and [ __ ] so I'm standing in this and
I realized I'm looking at paintings on
the wall and these paintings and these
reliefs was just beautiful and then I
realize when looking at the ceiling like
goddamn the craftsman shouldn't art
workers up this is art now look at the
floor like this art and I'm just
wondering like what inspired this like
who got so inspired to take an old
fortress make of the castle make it make
bigger gardens and then my art teacher
for the day just basically told me all
of this [ __ ] was made for women and
mistresses I was like for real oh yeah
the dogs diet or the reason you see so
many diners that was the King's mistress
I was like wow
like words I came back announced to my
wife I think I need a mistress it's big
as we've gotten I could go bigger for
the inspiration way she knows is it
technically considered a mistress that
the mistress was supposed to be you're a
[ __ ] mystery wives no you're [ __ ]
yeah I mean it's just a danger of how
close the [ __ ] is to threatening
their slot you know like you can York
you got a mistress all right
[ __ ] you buy our birthday
present and threatens the slot you know
what I mean no offer the head or some
[ __ ] like that but these guys were
enamored with their mistresses man
that's what they liked it only built
[ __ ] big [ __ ] palaces so you know I
think we should get we should definitely
make sure every like powerful guy we
like has a mistress oh yeah I mean
support for Kanye West to get amber back
you know we could get that next Jesus
album I really want that next record
like let's get let's get it threesomes
going let's get it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the undies we should be for y'all after
brunch minestrone got on a Sunday
whatever pants I said I leaves me undies
I said yes we got married now we live
bad underwear I'll never wear again and
check me out as I snap on his theorem
[Music]
you've perfected your wardrobe for what
about the stuff not everybody gets to
see me undies oh just seriously soft
feel good undies delivered right to your
door me undies are designed in LA it
made from sustainably sourced micro
Modell as a fabric three times softer
than cotton me undies soft it is soft
Lux undies coming in every change the
selection of classic colors both shades
and adventurous patterns so you can
tailor your undies to your own personal
style and guess what you can save time
and money each month with a monthly
subscription and if you're not ready for
a subscription that's okay you can still
save that's because me on DS is offering
you 20% off your first pair just use our
special URL me and Descamps slash
Hannibal and get 20% off your first pair
so go ahead
revamp your underwear drawer you deserve
once again that's me on DS comm slash
Hannibal me on DS comm slash Hannibal I
didn't know this table was gonna be here
but I like the candle I appreciate you
all I appreciate you all coming here at
2:30 and even though I don't have the
time I would like to know about your
lives individually and why they allow
you to be able to do this at like 11:00
a.m. on a Thursday and that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] packed I'm like how the [ __ ]
what are people I thought everybody went
to work from 8:00 to 5:00 people just in
these streets there's one there's at
least one graphic designer here
freelancers everywhere there's a couple
people that are high ranking and an
office job that can leave whenever they
want yeah I'm going I'm taking a late
lunch
we're just going to like a baseball game
during the day yeah like I wanna [ __ ]
Tuesday a [ __ ] noon game like what
the [ __ ] are just getting [ __ ] up
people just getting [ __ ] up like what
there's 10,000 people here what has
happened baseball games are empty as
[ __ ] when you go you like you feel bad
for the team like you're trying to
spread out across the Reese's fake-ass
Cubs fans I heard by the way bitter as
[ __ ] oh yes you know Cubs one world sees
I'm a bandwagon fan and I'm proudly so
I'm a bandwagon baseball fans yeah
that's okay [ __ ] that I hate baseball
and still hate it but I fake love it I
got into baseball as the Cubs started
getting good I started getting into the
new ones
yo his pitch countless to our family are
they bringing in they bringing in
Chapman in the seventh yeah
I don't give a [ __ ] about stuff like
that also I like the shift of Chicagoans
their view on Chapman before and after
he went to the Yankees Chapman was the
closer to Maine closer around a
seven-foot for the Cubs and you know he
had a situation allegedly some physical
[ __ ] with his wife domestic stuff his
wife and people you know he's a good
picture whatever
[ __ ] throw it at 100 we don't
care and then he went to the Yankees
after the World Series like [ __ ] wife
beater get out of Chicago you know it
was funny during during that like with
the whole thing with Cleveland and Cubs
in the World Series people were hating
on each other their league closer is a
wife beater it's like have you looked at
your your mascot the Cleveland Indians
like we can have this art
it's a stupid argument my kid that grew
up in Cleveland
you know even when you like eight or
nine you look at that Cleveland logo
like I don't know where racism is but I
think that's I was just like can you
because there's like one like there's
like the basic one and like there's
already a horrific but there's like one
that's got like it looks like a cartoon
with like the long Indian nose and so
long as I go and pointing down yeah it's
like a brown-skinned anything do nothing
I can't you do that yeah like is that a
thing like this [ __ ] and they still
is still around I'll be crazy if there
was a team like the Washington Chinamen
and just like the rice hatless you know
what I'm saying that's what is light but
what if it was a real dope ad would you
wear if it was a good logo now in [ __ ]
that's kind of weird the Washington
[ __ ] whose name and team's old
racists from World War two like the
Indians I mean it wasn't that like a
mistake like they weren't because like
they they cause I started calling them
Indians because they thought they're in
India and I just stuck but they're
Native Americans but they were like
[ __ ] we're just gonna keep calling
them Indians yeah cuz no one gives a
[ __ ] it's weird how just you just don't
see Native Americans and no one gives a
[ __ ] yeah we met some we did that that
Billings gig did I ever tell you about
that [ __ ] we would I was there there
Native Americans they when they go hard
I didn't know that that was such a
cultural thing like with the alcoholism
I saw oh it's really it's like you're
not in your head it's like whatever you
think you like y'all think I drink and I
kick it
y'all don't drink like they get done
drinking for tonight and then they have
their other liquor that they drink for
the rest of the night and this girl
drank down a pint of Jack Daniels you
ever seen him from the bottles from the
she pulled out of the purse first of all
she was hammered she's in my room and it
was weird as [ __ ] because I had a flight
in a couple hours
and she was like you first of all she
started the f-bomb started to fly she
was like you [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't
drink I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm just like oh
you know like [ __ ] USA Network's on
mutant your room you're like what's
happening right now I believe like I'm
like am I gonna leave her in my room to
tear up some [ __ ] like how do I get her
out of here she opened up her purse and
she had one of those plastic the pint
not not the small bottle but not the
fifth whatever is in the middle of that
she had a playa
she had the plastic Jack Daniels and
that turn took the top off turn that
[ __ ] up and Dre you ever seen it where
the shit's glug in like you getting a
dime a water-cooler see she turned it up
like that like a viral video yeah like
for real where like it was on YouTube
people like fake fake
that's apple juice bro look the camera
cuts this [ __ ] drink that [ __ ]
down in front of my face and like I
didn't know what to did like dude I bet
I don't know I didn't know you were
turned on bro I didn't do it was just
like I was like she might die I was like
she might do some crazy usually out my
name I couldn't she was there what
happened I [ __ ] bounced I went to the
airport and I realized like when I say
sent a car and I'm at the airport and I
realize that my cell phone was in her
car mmm and I went I went on my laptop
to see like that find your iPhone and my
iPhone was three about time I realized
therefore my phone was three hours away
at an Indian Reservation yeah she took
my [ __ ] to like an Indian Reservation in
Montana and I just wiped that [ __ ] I
mean you didn't try to call it and say
hey I think I think we had said
everything we had to say to each other I
think our relationship was over at that
point I want to keep it going excuse me
yeah yes that I had never seen no [ __ ]
like that in my life like she's having
have you ever been out drinking with
somebody and you like this might be a
crime like the way that she's drinking I
was like she might die and like then
it's like all me I feel bad because I we
were trying I was trying to think of
something cool to do for killer Mike it
was his birthday no I did was just bring
him here to talk
yeah we it was like I was like should we
have like somebody Pikachu costume was
I'm I'm trying to figure but we get we
party last night and didn't come up with
some and so he says I feel like a bad
friend he came through during the day on
his birthday
to do the podcast and then we didn't
even get like a cake or like some weed
or give him his candle or something yeah
give him the can I feel bad now did you
say that what thoughtful more well you
know they said Rickles used to Don
Rickles would give handwritten cards to
people and [ __ ] on that when he was
going there shows when you get Kimmel
handwritten cards just do thoughtful
[ __ ] well I just I think that's what we
all are single and I'm not saying that
in a cool way I think you're right man I
don't know how to I don't know how to do
the follow up like after like we kick it
once I'm like now what do I ask about
your sister yeah I don't know how to be
a good person
yeah I know I gotta do I gotta get
somebody that can copy my hair right and
so be thoughtful that's what it is
do you think girls think Rome and I
guess we have women here a romantic
gestures corny no they like or did they
they all like that like I forgot like
ask you to marry them in front of like
the x squared Christmas tree that's
corney's [ __ ] but do girls think that
though it depends on the person it's
about the situation delivery I think if
they like the person a lot then I think
it goes over but if it's just so here's
a question do you think girls would
prefer that you buy them something nice
and expensive or something
you took your time to make for them arts
and crafts yes I'm saying like a
macaroni art not even you know that's
just stupid [ __ ] but like you know say
you put together like this nice collage
that took like three months to make
that's like stuff that she likes and
it's nice framed or do you think she's
ready to just you ever get an Xbox or
something nice well maybe not xbox Xbox
you know you want to play this at my
place or like you know or like a nice
you know like a nice like an iPad or
something what do you think a girl would
rather want the the the effort of three
months thinking about her making
something or just here's a nice I like
that the really nice gift was an iPad
and not like a necklace 11 year olds
it's irrelevant I'm just you know you
know what the question is I don't I
don't think I mean I think she would I
think she says that she wants the
romantic [ __ ] what she wants I'm
practical for her life ya know collage
it's gonna be in the closet yeah with a
jacket on it like yeah I'd rather the
iPad too but but maybe this is why we're
single cuz we don't know what women want
yeah maybe no I I know what they want I
just don't want to give it to them no
you had a would you rather have a
thoughtful give that took a long time to
make or something that just something if
you pay attention to them and what they
like and their habits and then get
something that fits that if you show
that that's a good point or if you're
attentive and it shows that you get that
oh also yeah also trips yeah handle who
bought me a pimp-ass [ __ ] keyboard
for my housewarming gift thank you for
that no problem man what's that [ __ ] the
Rollie Rollie music nerd
it's a [ __ ] synthesizer committee
it's a MIDI controller which basically
means it's a keyboard that you play
through your laptop yeah what makes it
cool is the buttons are like rubber and
so like when you push the key it's not
just like the note but you could like
move it around and stop wobbling and
doing weird [ __ ] supposed to be
next-level stuff I haven't played with
it yet I haven't been doing as much
stand-up just cuz I've been playing the
theremin over trap songs lately he is
found as like true passion in music by a
theremin it is great I got this theorem
and it's great what brought it here but
I thought yeah cuz I told him I'm like
you know a theremin would be great for
the podcast cuz like you can [ __ ]
wave your hands around sounds cool and
he's like actually I got one of those
for my niece and nephew and they never
use that [ __ ] so he took that [ __ ] back
Indian well yeah Indian gifted it you
know what now after after I talk about
Native Americans I feel weird saying
that so yeah he's been [ __ ] on this
theremin on track like over trap beats
just going crazy while we're on the road
and I don't know what happened the other
day when we were by Coachella but I woke
up in the morning and this there was a
table that the theremin was on this
table was completely knocked over broken
glass everywhere and the theremin was on
the ground broken glass everywhere so
there man on the floor nobody just don't
care what happened he was blacked out
try to play music probably my theory is
you went Kurt Cobain on that theremin
but you rocked out here like just knock
that over I don't know what happened
first of all I'm not even I don't think
beyond a reasonable doubt there were
four of us standing in our house you
can't prove it was me
if it came down to it you can't prove it
was me I've really got into it so much
so that I had my assistant say okay I
had a theremin backstage at the show at
Atlanta's I have a theremin backstage
and it now is my backstage [ __ ] where I
was just there I'm in and out you guys
know what a theremin is right okay it
was like I'm doing an ad for but I get
no money from them but you know who I do
get money from
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
yes Congrats this is we hate the vortex
and laughing skull yeah yeah 25th
anniversary to the date 25 years oh I
love this spot 25 years of having a
business
yeah tough that is very tough yeah 92
1992 I was nine I wasn't yeah who knew
who knew I think you just whatever
business you start would just start with
alcohol and it'll figure itself out what
happens people are gonna drink it should
have been a [ __ ] vape shop that [ __ ]
would have been closed right wait the
last time we played here was it was it
the last time we played or watched the
Cavs win yeah yeah we watch the game I
was feeling I was filming spider-man
here and that's why I was doing this you
know what the weird thing about I got a
small role in spider-man and yeah and it
was they would I never saw the whole
script it was so secretive thing where
they were just give me my pages and then
that's it and so and they wouldn't just
email the pages they will bring them
sauce and I'm with vortex and then
they'd worse in a PA to bring me my to
script pages was it in a square wasn't
that even they could actually just told
me in my ear my last cuz my ceiling like
Peter what are you doing don't do that
Peter Peter oh wow you're athletic
Theater what's that spider but also just
by telling you all that based on their
behavior I'm worried that our mics will
just cut off huh did it come out already
come out July 4th weekend wait but how
many spider-man's are there it seems
like they reboot the reboots and I know
hopefully they're five of them yeah and
hopefully there's at least three or four
more I mean comic book movies are like
the [ __ ] like every I mean they know but
it's like it seems like they keep
rebooting spider-man and it's like a the
same story it's like Batman but Batman
goes he is adventures like it seems like
they keep making spider-man 1.0 until
they get here because they keep making
money off of it I mean the shit's not
you know this should if the ships work
and a lot of you know but have another
adventure they keep starting back a
square one with him getting bit in high
school I'm like we got that yeah but uh
you know if his spider-man is in high
school he needs a gym teacher so let's
follow him and the gym see to do
freshman sophomore junior senior year
and just you got a good lawyer whatever
your lawyer just for stood in that show
character had to be strong-armed in
every teacher was there when he was
fighting the Sandman's like let it
happen
don't fight it I can't I can't sit
through cartoon movies anymore unless
like I'm gonna like what I can't like
Pixar like a no-no I can't watch the
Pixar [ __ ] like like the exhibition like
I wasn't watching I should come back
I'll show you and like I have to like
the third do it pulls out a wand or
something I'm like I can't do this I
can't do an hour and a half of that the
CGI shadow the fake like the transfer I
can't do any I can't watch it I can't do
just can't do I appreciate it I'm like
Oh Wolverines claws look real as [ __ ]
what but I don't after he kills like the
third dude I'm like I'm straight I see
where this is going but did you see that
did you see that jungle book movie no
that [ __ ] was ill man animals is talking
like that you don't know say it for real
like that's the only time somebody has
said that and not been on a prison yard
animals is talking cuz oh the CGI is
[ __ ] dope like the wolves are talking
to each other but they got like normal
like human mouths and they're like well
like it's not like our lips on that but
they look the way they talk wait you
talk about like one of those old conan
bits no no no see this I'm saying it
doesn't look silly this [ __ ] looks dope
I'm saying
[ __ ] Bill Murray plays a goddamn bear
he played Baloo and he's just [ __ ]
talking to this kid like all the animals
talk the Panthers talking like he's
played by Ben Kingsley and it's crazy
cuz you get connected to these and it
was like you get attached to these
animal you hope you gotta see this
you're still in theaters but this [ __ ]
is both going to legit go right after
this yeah way Tony is like no imagine
going to the zoo and the animal just
comes out to users what's up man what's
going on you just have a conversation
with this animal it's like that [ __ ] man
no you're not how it makes this
conversation even weirder that you so
breathe I do you know what an animal
looks you now you connected like nah
yeah but you wish you knew what he was
thinking or like you wish you could tell
like wait is the zoo sad for y'all when
you go is it Sam it's like I feel like
the zoo is almost like it's almost like
the difference between a strip club and
what's the what's the what's the point
what's the one that's not a strip club
but it would have your chicks for less
burlesque yeah because because I feel
like burlesque is fun and joyful and
like strip clubs can drift into sand
real quick yeah like when you're at a
strip club and you like kicking with
your boys and you lock eyes with her
she's like I'm not at all like it just
takes you out of it that's what happens
at the zoo I'm like I feel bad for that
lion man right it's like what's prison
for animals basically what you think a
lion wants to be in that little a space
but it's getting fed regularly though
yeah but he wants to roam man those
lines don't look like it they look like
they know you see the paint especially
Tigers you see them walking in circles
and pacing and that's like a clear sign
of distress I'm not dr. Dolittle but I
know that much but unless though I don't
know sometimes a tease too much I get it
I get the performance aspect and they do
a lot of [ __ ] the moments are right on
beat and [ __ ] and I get it I like timing
that's cool but there's some time Nate
they tease off the taking off of their
glove yeah do you have titties on your
hands [ __ ] all sexy with your taking
your glove over though I don't think
it's necessary
just get that [ __ ] right off and as they
always is that the build-up is to show
any titties right at the song it's like
titties and no nipples yeah goofy wait
then yeah they don't show anything did I
at burlesque sometimes they do I think
no nipples nipples okay why who did that
whose idea was that
that should be your review of the show
on the website what [ __ ] why no nipples
whose idea was that
yeah it is not even their nipples that
much our nipples aren't super erotic
like that but is when you see the
nipples covered up why'd you take that
from me
it's true if you're gonna go that far to
where there's a whole breast and then
just the nipples I mean you might as
well just put the I don't isn't that
their chose I feel like it's a rule the
nudity rule that makes the nipple just
give me that [ __ ] man what do you want
to name it [ __ ] Ticket Master Live
Nation $5 extra charge
give me the nipples No it's like the Red
Hot Chili Peppers they used to play with
just socks on their dicks yeah yeah that
was a thing they'd go on stage early on
this is like when they were big they
were
they can't be nude on stage so they just
put socks on their dicks
yeah and just play their asses off how
many people would have read out Chili
Peppers
there's like 404 we got fish out there
you got flea you got what's the lead
singing name and then there's another
guy right there's a fourth guy one of
those four was not on board with that
[ __ ] at all one of them had to be
convinced on that [ __ ] all for real
we're just gonna be this with socks on
our dicks filled up we'll get the money
off for real dawg that's what I want to
do
that's the grower of the groove hey man
I gotta fluff up a little bit for you
man I don't want to do this I got bigger
dreams than this [ __ ] it's not
considered nudity if you got a sock on
your dick I think that's just what it
was for them that was was that that was
the 90s too right oh yeah you can't be
out there with just a sock on your dick
20:17 chick is snaps yeah but can you
have full frontal nudity cause how do
the puppetry of the penis dudes get away
with it they're all dick on the stage
what the [ __ ] is the puppetry two dudes
that can bent HP you know a perpetrator
I think no I know what it is but yeah
they have it at Comedy Festival Joe like
their dues I think they're like
Australian to some and they can take
their dick and Bend that [ __ ] like our
animal below like a
like a balloon yellow never heard reason
I can't see because that would pass out
of myself some [ __ ] like that I can't do
it but like they're they like draw they
like draw like fans wait [ __ ] has heard
of puppetry of the penis I've heard of
it I thank you I didn't never I didn't
know that they were actually I think I
dig animals I just thought it was I
don't know about metaphors but I think
they're like dudes they they can take
their balls and pull their balls up and
wrap their dhikr they're like dudes that
could they have a lot of I don't know
actually I don't I've never seen it yet
but they must be able to do enough [ __ ]
to do an hour show so they just make
sculptures this is they can release to
me yeah I didn't think it was actual
they were moving their dicks around
I thought puppetry of the penis was just
about how our penises turns us into
different people didn't we really are I
mean I have it but I don't know what
comedy fest I did but they were gonna be
there like the next night like they have
hour-long shows the power of like it's
like four dudes and they can all do
crazy [ __ ] I make sculptures together
I'm sure they tied it dicks together I
don't know
but they like it crazy it's like I feel
I care about things I'm sure they look
it up now we got founds no let's not do
that
that's weird can you could you sit
through something like done
no I just I can't I can't be pop my head
in and be like that's weird
I'm out you know but like that's all
like but then you guys think for the
closer if you going in there and I see
what they go in this way it's true I
don't know all right so an hour
burlesque Hannibal or an hour to stroke
love here to decide uh Who am I with Who
am I wit your with us me and so how I
would say an hour of burlesque just
because
we're in Atlanta though so this is
different mistakes I have reason and
this better than what you're okay I was
a burlesque because or less girls
[Laughter]
[Music]
because this is less there's this yeah
where the strip club girl I don't [ __ ]
customers unless they're young jeezy
[Laughter]
let's go let's go to the next bar
afterwards I work in middle management
but I do this for fun
yeah and you can honestly say I really
enjoyed your performance it's all core
work now sometimes strippers on a poem
like damn I surprised well I would hear
it's like a sport just get crazy out and
then in like Portland it's like just
part of the decor here's a thing with a
strip club if you try to talk to a
stripper afterwards you have to deal
with her vibe possibly I'm having some
other [ __ ] to just through
$1,000 and singles on her body so her
mental state is totally different than
it just was dancing around with tassels
and yeah theater [ __ ] the strippers just
have a focuses throwing money on her
titties on beat she's feeling herself
away more than two brothers threw money
on her in a cool way
and one of the dollars might hit you you
know and then you try to talk to her she
like didn't three dollars of mine hit
you in the face earlier yeah I had I had
I got scarred early at a stroke I think
I told you I first moved to Miami and
this is back I'm like you know like when
you super broken
like maybe 150 bucks to last me for like
10 days and my homeboy took me a strip
club in Miami Beach called the dollhouse
and never forget it I was bad as a
middle school teacher I was broke as
[ __ ] and I had like a hundred and I had
like a five and a ten and she came over
and she was near the thing and I just
reached in my wallet and put some money
in her garter and I looked and as she
was standing up I just seen the $100
bills starting to drift with her and I
gave her the hundred instead of the five
oh and I was like that was like my meal
money for the week like on her thigh
right and she just walked away I can't
ask for it back and I'm sitting in a
barn I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm broke as [ __ ]
now get close and she came up to me
after she saw how much money I gave her
she was like hey you wanna [ __ ]
probably dance I was like get the [ __ ]
away from me like I was like there's
like you have everything I own the
smooth way you should have been like
listen come live with me
the smooth way is you gonna just be like
excuse me do you have change cuz I just
give you a whole hundred and then that
might not work because then she might
have gave you like a couple 20s back
what I gave you a hundred I want some
change it's a win situation but
sometimes you gotta force them I was so
bit well I saw a dude get his ass kicked
at the strip club one of my first times
ever going I got scarred by that [ __ ]
like I was in high school he got beat up
I just know cuz you know like when you
18 nervous in a strip club and I was
just just sitting there and he was like
a nerdy kind of older white dude and I
just heard like a slap like I hurts my
face get slapped and I turn and this
black stripper stood up and she goes
this [ __ ] not tipping like
that's all and I'm like I've been a
strip club ten minutes once in my life
they grab his phone forgotten they
literally kicked him out like used his
head to open the door and threw him the
[ __ ] outside in the wintertime in
Cleveland I was like I ain't never
touching a stripper ever like I was I
think that [ __ ] permanently affected how
I like view strip clubs like when I gave
her all my money I was like that was
just guys playing damn
haha well with that story you've just
given me a new idea for podcast guess
this is dudeism violently kicked out of
strippers have you just rolled out
anywhere thrown yes why do you think I
asked you that question yeah literally
throw yes physically thrown it was just
as in fresh Purim
yes in Chicago on six corners is a major
intersection in Wicker Park North Avenue
Milwaukee and Damon it was the spot
right on the corner I forget the name of
it but I don't know if I didn't have my
ID or what it was but this guy didn't he
said no you can't get in you can't get
in and so then were you famous at this
one this was eight years ago no this is
more than this was like when I was 22 or
23 I'll still spending at travia
right I was really a kid yeah and and so
I went in I was trying to get in he said
no and then I ended up sneaking in the
side door I think some balls
I get in a side door and it wasn't even
a great crazy vibe it was just a bar
basically but I wasn't happy to be in
sounds just happy to sneak in some [ __ ]
you not even supposed to be in and it
wasn't even a there wasn't even a hey
what would you up to over here hey you
it wasn't none of that I was just lifted
[Laughter]
it was no conversation hey this was
picked up during the Hannibal skinny
days too
[Laughter]
you're easier to throw this is free
drinking and eating but yeah he threw me
the [ __ ] out and I don't remember like
damn I was that was crazy what do you do
once you've been throwing that did you
hit the ground like he threw you the
[ __ ] outside or he just shoves you out
the door he picked me up my feet wasn't
touching
I wasn't walked out it wasn't a
conversation he picked up and put out he
didn't punch me anything he was
surprisingly efficient about the whole
situation dust yourself off and you walk
away that's it whoa I just get put the
[ __ ] out like you time-traveled like you
just lifted me and put me in so you know
that's a popular intersection so I will
be hanging out out there a lot and I
would look like doesn't [ __ ] do but I
never came I never came at him like what
the [ __ ] it was his eye it was I in my
head yeah we talked about this we talked
about this before on another pocket but
that's like the most degrading thing
that one man could do to another man is
literally pick him up and throw him
right that's pretty degrading as wanted
more degrading and kicked in the face
that's that's right yeah but I mean a
kick in the face is also just like I
mean it's the Grady but it's also cool
yeah but like there's nothing cool about
getting picked up in the white house
getting kicked in the face cold like if
you're the guy kicking on that's cool as
[ __ ] some kung fu [ __ ] yeah but like if
you picking somebody up and throwing
them it's not really that cool but it's
super degrading I think you should just
learn even if you never learn martial
arts
you should just learn how to throw like
a kick and just like if you wanna fight
a do you separate and just throw like a
fake air kick like this is what I got
mmm-hmm I think that [ __ ] would
intimidate the [ __ ] I didn't buy you
with the fight even if you don't know
how to really use the kick in the real
fight I would be like this [ __ ]
that's what I was always a huge Shawn
Michaels
yeah the restless Shawn Michaels cuz he
was just saying people in the face
massage facial kick people he would he
was a good and then kick somebody in the
face it was a good move for him
Hanako would you say you you you would
you say you think you've done like you
you've had your last fistfight
I think I'm retired I got jumped in the
back by a bouncer one time I ain't even
do [ __ ] and I was like I'm done no there
will be a time in your life where I
think I hope I have in my spirit my my
spirit wants to fight sometimes but my
mind knows that it'll be on
WorldStarHipHop no matter what the
outcome no matter where the lows of your
worlds like hip hop and I don't wanna
have a public record of me in a physical
altercation is a here's a lesson you got
clothes or you had one [ __ ] well I've
slapped a couple of photos over the past
few years this one should be getting
into a Cadillac as you say at the US
Open outsider it not in the US over but
it's trying to get into the US over
these [ __ ] opening slap and gross it
was justified I'm not just a violent
dude this is bad for my bread but I had
to slap him this dude I want update
going to the US Open it's chill nobody
recognized me going in his neck the
crowds not my crowd but one [ __ ]
knew me and he had like I don't know if
he was mentally challenged or if he was
on Molly he just had weird eyeballs and
he comes up to me
you'll calm down he's like oh you
Hannibal Burres yeah I am but still calm
down you're making me feel weird and you
can't get a picture
I say yeah you think this is take a
picture and he had his phone and his
hand was shaking so much from whatever
you don't know if he was feeling or the
drugs or and so his hand was shaking too
much to take the picture I grabbed the
phone and I take I snap a couple of
pitches I said thank you and I
appreciate you and we keep walking and
then he comes up on us and he is like yo
that picture it was blurry it was blue
no man we already did this can we take
another one we walk a little bit further
but how big is do dude is maybe maybe a
little shorter to me but around the same
size yeah why got crazy eyes and so we
walk a little bit further Internet I
feel a hand on my shoulder and and it is
him and he's forcing oh yeah and so
that's when I I get him off of me and I
slap him in his face and it was right in
front of the police just as we were
getting to the metal detectors and they
just let it right well we saw the whole
[ __ ] going on like did me a black dude
just slap a white person at a tennis of
it and nothing to have it that that's
true progress we did it and so at the US
Open is in the it's in Queens
and so there's about four or five
different courts at this spot and so so
we went the wrong one so we have to
double back and then we walk again and
then in my free field
kind of main courtyard I see somebody
walking towards me with a phone and it's
to do I'm in my in my mind while trying
to be positive
maybe he's walking up to apologize but
this dude walks away he's recorded
Hannibal Burres why'd you slap in the
face
Oh Hannibal Burres why just slap me in
the face and and so I was about to pop
off on him
luckily she calmed me down real quick
because if I were to if I were to pop it
would have been me admitting that I
actually slapped him in the face on
camera so I just chilled out and I
walked as his kiosk as has some water I
just went I was just trying to calm down
cuz I was more heated than ever been cuz
I can't find the tennis court that we
actually want to be at and also there's
this weirdo and he's right next to me
but his it was snapchat then he just
took so was looping and he's right next
to me so I'll just hit Hannibal Burres
why'd you slap me in the face Hannibal
Burres why'd you slap in the face
Hannibal Buress watches that and so I'm
just getting furious but I was let him
have that footage is good I'm just
trying to play this cool and then he
went to film me again right there and so
I just snatched his phone from and threw
[Laughter]
I think I would have stopped it I
stopped it it was great to watch my
Ferguson snap out from being an [ __ ]
to just learning to chase their phone
like a dog
no I was mad but now I know if I mean I
hopefully I don't never have that type
of situation again well I was like oh I
said it took the case off I know II had
an outer bus
his phone was unscathed
[Laughter]
yeah it was [ __ ] crazy
and then we didn't even find a tennis
court we were trying to go to for
another hour and a half down yeah it was
a mess ever since snapchat I feel like
people have just been getting real
relentless with like getting in your
[ __ ] with the social media stuff like
like snapchat like ignited this fire I
just always feel like a misdirect
because people asked for a picture but
then it's a snapchat video if it's music
playing have you had a legit stalker yet
but just people did say stuff a lot have
to stop I move around without gigs
enough without publicized gigs and tour
dates where I'm traveling for fun so
it's tough to and I don't if I'm
traveling just to hang out
I don't tweet or Instagram where I am so
that people can't be that weird yeah I
feel like I don't know maybe it's just
me being naive I feel like every female
friend that I have has had a legit
stalker
I even know that [ __ ] was real as [ __ ]
like me having like real ass like
girls clap anybody here at a real last
talker that's enough like a real like a
sit outside yeah oh yeah well that
happened remember I was in Brooklyn I
was with widow girl and her stalker
walked into the bar and she just wasn't
she wasn't the same person he was in the
bar but he was acting we we were it was
when New Yorkers have a crazy weather
and we ducked into this bar in Brooklyn
and she was talking to me and then she
just stopped talking and she was like we
need to go right now and to the point
where we had just bought two drinks like
she was like she wanted to walk out on
our template she want to even pay she's
like we need to go and she was like I
guess she filed a restraining order on
do but he can't give a [ __ ] he just came
in sat right behind me and just stared
at her but I didn't know I just thought
he's a random dude at the bar she and
telling me like yo my stalker is 12
inches behind you maybe you might want
to turn around
she and tell me that [ __ ] so like we
just walked out and so she walked out
she just to burst into tears and she's
like he's been following me for years
and like this guy moved to my name she
was like he lives like he lived in like
Jamaica like there's like no way to this
they would be in a bar on a Monday now
you know during the [ __ ] hailstorm
like she's like this do like just fouls
her around oh please can't do [ __ ] until
he goes yes yeah yeah that's just real
isn't cuz like I think for dudes because
we are is it an ex oh no that's her I
think it's a guy she dated briefly but
it's like I don't know what do you do
let it go there you go dude shouldn't be
doing that but she probably was great at
sex like I'm just trying to hang out
until she sees maybe comes together
again there's well there's a weird mixed
message yeah and movies and [ __ ] what
you see is like you know I just your
grandfather he asked me to date him 11
times before I said yes I'm like that
stalker [ __ ] but in movies they romantic
like I'm gonna be right here at this bus
stop and ask you out everyday I'm like
that's crazy as [ __ ]
but it's looked at as being romantic and
even songs like sting I'll be watching
you stalking yeah but it ended up work
it out it's not giving me positive
reinforcement say any stalkers listening
but you communicate is it you say hey
I'm here that's different than just
being there that dude was just there he
didn't say what's up right ain't say
nothing see I would never do something
like that yeah that's beneath me if I
see something I'm so I'm gonna hey
what's up cuz why why come there if you
don't speak but you go there by yourself
because that's crazy
I would go say hey what's up I really
like what we had I wouldn't do it over
and over after one I think no you know I
wasn't a stalker cuz I was I did one
overt event and then one of the flash
mob or not a flash mob I just showed up
uninvited okay let's just pop it up and
she was with it though who knows yeah
but yeah eventually but I think if you
just keep on showing up I think you get
one I think one stalker like behavior is
fine popping up at work popping up at
the place or somewhere at a bar pop it
up but you have to speak you have to say
your business
and if it doesn't go well don't be
and don't do anything creepy like
sitting your car in the dark or like you
also emotionally unstable
[Laughter]
somebody preciate it
well it's Tony Trail al Jackson
killing Mike thank you - laughing skull
congratulations - for sex 25 years in
business Schlotzsky's flood thank you -
you've come to booth thank you watching
the song hope you all enjoyed it have
some drinks in a good day everybody lady
[Music]
you
[Music]